les russes vont devoir faire une croix
sur les big mac et les vanilla lattes et
les grandes chaînes de fast-food
occidentale coupe les ponts avec la
russie
mcdonald's ferme temporairement ses 850
restaurant dans le pays cela représente
3 % du bénéfice opérationnel du groupe
dans un communiqué le géant américain
prend clairement position contre la
guerre en ukraine la crise humanitaire a
causé des souffrances indicibles à des
gens innocents nous rejoignons le reste
du monde en condamnant ces agressions et
cette violence pour certains
spécialistes le départ de mcdonnell de
russie est synonyme d'un retour en
arrière
lorsque mcdonald's s'installer en union
soviétique cela a envoyé un signal
d'ouverture c'était un pas vers
l'établissement d'un lien de confiance
et de coopération que la russie et
l'occident à présent les restaurants
mcdonald's sont tous fermés donc ce
départ du marché russe met un terme à
cette époque
d'autres géants comme la chaîne de cafés
starbucks suspendent leurs activités sur
place de même pour coca cola et pepsi
qui vont arrêter d'exporter leur boisson
vers la russie ces compagnies imite
ainsi d'autres entreprises de
l'industrie du divertissement et du
secteur bancaire qui avait déjà pris
leurs distances avec le pays de vladimir
poutine ces grands groupes 7 surtout à
la pression de l'opinion publique qui
appelait à les boycotter sur les réseaux
sociaux au total plus de 290 grandes
entreprises ayant une présence
importante en russie ont annoncé leur
retrait